[Applauso]
[Musica]
i ghiacciai sono i migliori indicatori
dei cambiamenti climatici
chissà quante volte l'avete sentito dire
sempre vengono chiamati di acciaio ogni
volta che si parla di problemi globali i
problemi ambientali globali come in
questi giorni ma spesso non si dice che
cosa sono e non si danno delle
motivazioni del perché dovrebbero essere
i migliori testimoni del clima che
cambia attraverso l'incontro di oggi
condividendo con voi la mia esperienza e
la mia passione spero di riuscire a
svelarvi qualcosa in più su queste
meravigliose ed effimere presenze delle
nostre montagne e di capire quindi se
davvero sono i migliori a testimoniarci
il clima che cambia
cominciamo con delle immagini questo è
un gigante del parco dello stelvio
ghiacciaio dei forni questo ghiacciaio
in lombardia è arretrato di oltre due
chilometri negli ultimi 150 anni
nello stesso periodo di tempo la
temperatura dell'aria è aumentata di
poco meno di 2 gradi
certo non è l'unico elemento del mondo
naturale dei sistemi naturali che
risponde al clima che cambia risponde
anche la foresta innalzando il limite
degli alberi
rispondono gli animali e le piante
andando incontro dapprima degli stress e
spesso rischiando l'estinzione
ma chi di noi è in grado di capire
subito che il limite della foresta si
sta alzando che un animale una pianta
sono vicini all'estinzione
bisogna avere un occhio allenato educato
per cogliere queste peculiarità queste
particolarità dell'ambiente naturale un
arretramento invece di oltre di due
chilometri è innegabile e chiaro a tutti
limpido cristallino inequivocabile e ci
dice che qualcosa sta cambiando il clima
i ghiacciai poi sono acqua in scatola
sono acqua allo stato solido annidata
nelle nostre montagne che si rende
disponibile durante la fusione estiva
per mitigare soprattutto le magre
periodi siccitosi ma anche per fornire
energia elettrica che sia acqua e
scatola è molto chiaro in molti posti
del mondo
non solo alpini dove ghiacciai sono
molto più estese ad esempio in karakorum
questo è un villaggio del pakistan dove
le persone compiono svariati viaggi
durante la settimana di parecchi
chilometri per raggiungere il ghiacciaio
prenderne nei blocchi che poi verranno
utilizzati al villaggio scop
idropotabile quindi davvero e acqua e
scatola il ghiaccio di ghiacciaio è
particolarissimo è diverso dal ghiaccio
marino ad esempio dal ghiaccio che
possiamo produrre noi nel freezer di
casa il ghiaccio marino il ghiaccio che
produciamo noi è semplicemente acqua
congelata il ghiaccio di ghiacciaio si
forma molto lentamente con un processo
di trasformazione di metamorfismo della
neve così si chiama la neve precipita e
quando precipita e leggera pesa solo 100
kg al metro cubo e poi si accumula
strato dopo strato e se non fonde
durante l'estate e sopravvive ad un po
di estati si può trasformare in ghiaccio
di ghiacciaio che ha una densità ben
diversa a 917 kg al metro cubo
questo processo è lento ha bisogno di
dieci anni circa sulle alpi addirittura
di un secolo in antartide
grazie al fatto che il ghiaccio e deriva
dalle nevicate rimane intrappolato al
suo interno anche molto altro
soprattutto sostanze volatili per lo più
inquinanti
per esempio detergenti ritardanti di
fiamma pesticidi che viaggiano partendo
dalle nostre città o delle campagne in
atmosfera raggiungono le alte vette e li
precipitano insieme alla neve e si
trasformano in ghiaccio quindi il
ghiacciaio da una parte tiene memoria
anche del nostro impatto chimico
sull'ambiente quindi non solo
dell'impatto sul clima e dall'altro
questi inquinanti prima o poi vengono
rilasciati quando il ghiaccio fonde e in
questi anni sta fondendo molto
intensamente quindi noi li ritroviamo
poi nei fiumi nei laghi nei mari e anche
nei piatti di cibo di casa nostra perché
poi entrano nella catena alimentare il
ghiacciaio non sta fermo si muove si
muove per scivolamento deformazione e
questo è evidente
se ci si va sopra sono bellissimi
ghiacciai perché sono solcati da
crepacci da fratture che sono
conseguenza proprio della deformazione
del ghiaccio per il movimento
questa è una proprietà incredibile
pensate non ci sono altri elementi del
paesaggio fisico che si muovono invece
il ghiacciaio si muove certo non ce ne
accorgiamo si muove di pochi centimetri
al giorno che vuol dire qualche decina
di metri all'anno ma si muove
allora potreste dirmi ma come mai non li
vediamo avanzare non li vediamo arrivare
nelle valli non li vediamo no arrivare
nelle valli perché durante l'estate
l'aria calda che ormai prevale con il
cambiamento climatico fa sì che vada
incontro fusione più ghiaccio di quello
che ne arriva grazie al movimento quindi
noi vediamo un accorciamento continua
degli acciai anche se loro si muovono
continuamente scendono verso di noi
verso le valli di che colore è il
ghiaccio glaciale
immagino che tutti voi pensate sia
bianco o qualcuno blu perché
nell'immaginario comune il ghiaccio di
ghiacciaio e bianco gli acciai sono
candidi e immacolati e invece guardate
queste foto
questi sono i ghiacciai di casa nostra
di lombardia sono grigiastri marroncini
perché si stanno annerendo è un fenomeno
globale che si chiama dark e l'ing i
ghiacciai cioè cambiano pelle se
anneriscono a seguito del cambiamento
climatico perché le pareti rocciose
hanno delle perdite di detrito delle
frane più frequenti e quindi si
ammantano di detrito e ha seguito anche
del nostro impatto sull'ambiente
perché la fuliggine il particolato
derivante dai motori diesel piuttosto
che dagli incendi boschivi rendono il
ghiaccio sempre più grigio e questo è un
problema
voi d'estate per esempio come preferite
vestirvi in genere sotto il sole ci
vestiamo di colori chiari perché perché
ovviamente in questo modo riflettiamo di
più la radiazione solare e avvertiamo di
meno la calura
ecco i ghiacciai non possono scegliere i
loro vestiti d'estate sono sempre
vestiti di scuro assorbono continuamente
di più la radio
solare si riscaldano di più e fondono
molto molto intensamente questo è
evidente confrontando delle foto come
quella che vi propongo ma è ancora più
evidente applicando delle tecnologie
nuove come il telerilevamento che vuol
dire osservare la terra dallo spazio
utilizzando satelliti aerei e droni noi
con i satelliti per esempio abbiamo
studiato e di ace del parco dello
stelvio
i ghiacciai del parco dello stelvio sono
passati dal 17 per cento di copertura
detritica nel 2003 al oltre il 30 per
cento nel 2012 quindi un annerimento un
darkening evidente sembra i satelliti ci
dicono non solo quanti ghiacciai sono
neri ma anche quantomeno riflettono la
radiazione solare
lo abbiamo fatto per il parco dello
stelvio dal 1987 con delle immagini
satellitari pioniere fino ai giorni
nostri e abbiamo visto che
effettivamente la riflettanza diminuisce
i ghiacciai quindi sono sempre più neri
e fondono sempre più intensamente ora
una domanda
questo è il nostro drone con cui si
chiami di acciai con estrema risoluzione
e ci conferma questo annerimento ora una
domanda quanti ci sono i ghiacciai in
italia quanti sono solo qualche decina
qualche centinaio
vi sto parlando di qualcosa che è raro è
poco diffuso o di qualcosa che è molto
presente sulle nostre montagne
qualche decina ho sentito è allora vi
stupirò i ghiacciai in italia e li
abbiamo inventariati con un catasto un
catasto che veniva più fatto da 60 anni
che con il mio gruppo di ricerca abbiamo
prodotto sono 903 903 ghiacciai di cui
902 sulle alpi è uno solo e in appennino
il ghiacciaio del calderone nel gruppo
del gran sasso sono molto piccoli
pensate che tutti insieme si estendono a
coprire la superficie del lago di garda
368 chilometri quadri per darvi un'idea
di quanto è questo
numero e si sono ridotti negli ultimi 60
anni
l'essenza per cento che vuol dire di 157
chilometri quadri che più o meno la
superficie del lago di como
il loro numero invece aumentato e questo
sembra un controsenso
uno può dire ma come ci stai dicendo che
i ghiacciai si sono ridotti che la loro
superficie è così ridotto e sono
aumentati di numero certo perché
aumentano le finestre rocciose e questo
è ovviamente portano alla frammentazione
del ghiacciaio e alla produzione di
tanti ghiacciai piccoli a partire da
pochi di acciai grandi come in questo
caso ora l'acqua che deriva dai
ghiacciai è davvero importante è un
quantitativo sensibile oppure è poca per
rispondere a questo abbiamo confrontato
del materiale sempre da telerilevamento
e per regione lombardia tra il 1981 al
abbiamo scelto queste due date perché
per queste due date avevamo a
disposizione del materiale ad altissima
risoluzione emerso che in questo periodo
di tempo gli acciai di lombardia si sono
ridotti di 1.5 km cubi di ghiaccio che
vuol dire 1496 miliardi di litri di
acqua in 26 anni
questo numero né se lo dividiamo per i
26 anni ci dà 57.5 milioni di metri cubi
di acqua all'anno che nostri ghiacciai
non hanno perso ci hanno donato hanno
rilasciato nel periodo estivo e santo o
e poco per riuscire a dire sarà tanto o
poco dobbiamo confrontare questo numero
con tutta l'acqua che precipita in
lombardia durante l'anno sotto forma di
neve o di pioggia in lombardia
precipitano 27 miliardi di metri cubi di
acqua quindi 57 milioni contro 27
miliardi sono una lacrima una lacrima
che però percepita nel periodo più
importante quando effettivamente
dobbiamo mitigare le magre e perini
siccitose ora un'altra domanda che ci
siamo posti è se quest'acqua ha un ruolo
importante per la produzione di energia
idroelettrica
per fare questo con il politecnico il
nostro partner abbiamo valutato la
produzione di energia idroelettrica
nella provincia di sogno negli ultimi 26
anni
quantificando quanta acqua e arrivava
dalla fusione nivale quanta acqua e
arrivava dalla fusione glaciale e dalle
piogge
abbiamo diviso la provincia di sondrio
due aree o in un area c'erano solo di
acciaierie e nell'altra non c'erano i
ghiacciai ma c'erano comunque le dighe i
nostri conti ci hanno evidenziato che
nel settore dove erano presenti i
ghiacciai le dighe si sono giovate fino
al 20 per cento dell'acqua diffusione
grecia le per la produzione di energia è
una quantitativo modesto il 20 per cento
ma pensate tra qualche anno quando non
ci saranno più i ghiacciai questo 20 per
cento verrà a mancare e dovremo fare i
conti alpi senza di acciai è possibile
purtroppo è possibile se non cambieremo
radicalmente le nostre abitudini passato
delle forme più sostenibili sostenendo
l'economia circolare andremo sempre più
ad aumentare gas serra in atmosfera
modificheremo il clima e andremo
incontro a una riduzione dei ghiacciai
fin quasi alla loro scomparsa
possiamo fare qualcosa sicuramente sì
pochi sanno che in italia applicando
politiche di riduzione delle emissioni
già ha ridotto del 15 per cento le
emissioni di gas serra
certo questo non basta dobbiamo
aggiungere fare qualcos'altro anche noi
ogni singolo cittadino per aiutarci in
questo con il mio dipartimento di
scienze politiche ambientali abbiamo
prodotto un test di autovalutazione
proposto a tutti i cittadini è poi stato
sul sito web dove in forma anonima
ciascuno di noi
rispondendo delle semplici domande può
quantificare il suo impatto sul clima
la sua impronta climatica così si chiama
quindi rispondendo alle domande in forma
anonima che sono relative al
riscaldamento all'illuminazione
trasporti all'alimentazione e sa come
ricicliamo i rifiuti si può capire
quanti co2 equivalente e mettiamo ogni
anno la proposta di fare il test
ognuno di noi e poi di rifarlo una
seconda volta
modificando qualcuna delle risposte per
capire come possiamo risparmiare
emissioni semplicemente cambiando le
nostre abitudini e come possiamo anche
risparmiare nel nostro portafoglio
perché sicuramente più conveniente aiuta
il clima e ridurre le nostre emissioni
di gas climalteranti
ora spero dopo quest'incontro di aver
acceso o riacceso la vostra passione il
vostro interesse per i ghiacciai
spero che ciascuno di voi trovi il tempo
per andare a vedere un ghiacciaio magari
anche solo dalla terrazza di un rifugio
ricordandovi quando lo ammirate che non
sarà lì per sempre ma lì adesso ora per
ricordarci che il pianeta al creato
ci sono affidati e dobbiamo averne cura
grazie
[Applauso]